a self-driving truck packed with beer
has made its first delivery you might
remember that I told you a little while
back about uber buying auto auto is a
company that had a self-driving truck
technology which Buber has purchased and
now there's been what summer are
attributing to sort of a publicity stunt
a self-driving truck with nobody behind
the wheel but there was a sort of
supervisor riding in the cab actually
drove together teamed up with
anheuser-busch InBev the first
driverless truck delivery of beer and
there was a police cruiser in tow it
drove a hundred and twenty miles when
the driver was just hanging out in the
sleeper cab and it's mostly a stunt they
basically wanted to show that the
building blocks of self-driving truck
technology are there a B InBev which is
anheuser-busch the company that makes a
lot of the beer that maybe you drink
they said they could save 50 million
dollars a year in the US if they can
deploy these autonomous trucks across
their entire distribution network and
that's even if drivers continue to be
doing ride alongs and supplementing the
technology the fuel cost reduction and
the more frequent delivery schedule and
the ability to drive way more hours than
a human driver is able to drive would
reduce costs drastically now here's
where it starts to get a little funny
one of the spokespeople for uber said
that they don't plan to build their own
trucks and want to partner with
automakers and also that they may
continue to use the supervision of
humans indefinitely I just don't buy it
Pat I mean it that we know that the
building blocks are there for not
needing a human in the car and in the
cab the car the truck whatever the case
may be I don't buy for a second that
indefinitely the idea is - oh it'll be
self-driving but we're still going to
pay someone to just ride along maybe at
the beginning maybe until the law gets
sorted out but I don't see it long-term
right it's part of the transition I
would bet and how easy of a job would it
be to - to be the driver sort of speak
but you're the cars moving autonomously
so you just have to kind of watch
everything over
yeah I mean you just have to be
attentive for four long shifts the US
trucking industry has so much to lose
and also so much to gain from autonomous
trucks right I mean so much to lose in
that they're going to lose jobs millions
of jobs are going to be lost there
there's an estimate that there's about
three and a half million professional
truck drivers in the US some estimates
are higher some are a little bit lower
those are all jobs which by and large
will be eliminated that's just going to
happen when I say that there's a lot to
gain what I mean is that the trucking
industry is responsible for and
connected to many many accidents and
fatalities and those could be reduced
drastically the idea of a tired driver
making mistakes
the idea of driver error will be almost
completely eliminated with this
technology I see this as unavoidable it
just doesn't make sense to think we're
going to Mars in the next ten years
which I believe that we are by 2026 I
think that there will be at least an
unmanned a supply mission to Mars to
start some kind of exploration there
robotic surgery continues to advance all
of these innovations but still in 15
years we're going to have people
susceptible to tiredness able to drive
only a portion of the day restricted by
physical and legal constraints manually
driving massive trucks around our
highways it's just impossible to believe
and a fascinating angle to this too is
at what point do we outlaw manual manual
driving just just having people do it
but yeah I know that people are gonna be
responsible for more accidents than
these automated vehicles are
conservatives talk about that a lot
about the loss of freedom and just how
fundamentally American it is to get out
there and to drive around it I get it I
enjoy driving in many ways but the
reality is at least as far as highway
trips go and that's the initial thing
here with the driverless trucks which is
it's still complex to maneuver and back
in these trucks at loading docks and in
cities I mean in our studio area here a
lot of trucks drive around these are
tight corners that technology is going
to be further off in terms of automation
but a
far as the highway driving for trucks
and as far as personal driving I would
love it if on a highway trip I didn't
have to drive it all and I could just do
make phone calls or send text messages
read articles whatever that that's going
to happen and I personally look forward
to it I think that there will be
opportunities to drive no matter what
and even if we start moving away from
driving for transportation purposes
particularly on the highway I don't
think we're going to lose this activity
of driving that many people like and of
course we know that technology is going
to approve too
I mean there has been some fatalities
from autonomous cars and that has to be
worked on yeah although if you actually
look at the details you you can't
necessarily attribute it to it being an
autonomous vehicle per se yeah I mean
I'd have to look at the story again yeah
also there's an issue of passing trucks
I mean autonomous cars want to veer off
too much away from these trucks as a lot
of people do to all stuff that
technology I am sure is going to
eventually figure out